what's your
view let me put on my russian hat which
believes that life is
like russian hats by the way if you have
one i would like this those are
ridiculous yes
but in a delightful way but sure
what do you think is the role of uh we
talked about balance a little bit
what do you think is the role of
hardship in education
like i think the biggest things i've
learned
like th what made me fall in love with
math for example
is by being bad at it until i got good
at it
so like like struggling with a problem
which increased the level of joy i felt
when i finally figured it out
and it always felt with me with teachers
especially modern discussions of
education how can we make
education more fun more engaging more
all those things
well from my perspective it's like
you're maybe missing the point
that education that life is suffering
education is supposed to be hard and
that actually what
increases the joy you feel when you
actually learn something
is that ridiculous do you like to see
your students suffer
okay so this may be a point where we
differ i'd suspect not
do go on well what would your answer be
i want to hear you first okay well i
would i was going to not answer the
question
do you know what this dude is i was
going to hear them suffer no no no no i
was
i was going to say that there's i think
there's a
distinction that you can make in the
kind of suffering right so i think
you can be in a mode where you're you're
suffering in a hopeless way
versus you're suffering in a hopeful way
right where you're like you can see
that if you that you still have you can
still imagine getting
to the end right and as long as people
are in that mindset where they're
struggling but
it's not a hopeless kind of struggling
that's
that's productive i think that's really
helpful but it's struggling like if
you break their will if you leave them
hopeless
no that don't sure some people are going
to whatever lift themselves up by their
bootstraps but like
mostly you give up and certainly it
takes the joy out of it and
you're not going to spend a lot of time
on something that brings you no joy
so it's a it is a bit of a delicate
balance right you have to thwart people
in a way that they still believe that
there's a way through
right so that's a that we strongly agree
actually so i think
well first off struggling and suffering
aren't the same thing
right being poetic oh no no i actually
appreciate the poetry and i one of the
reasons i appreciate it is that they are
often the same thing and often quite
different right so you can struggle
without suffering you certainly
suffer suffer suffer pretty easily you
don't necessarily have to struggle to
suffer
so i think that you want people to
struggle but that hope matters
you have to they have to understand that
they're going to get through it on the
other side
and it's very easy to confuse the two
i actually think brown university has a
very just
philosophically has a very different
take on the relationship with their
students particularly undergrads from
say
a place like georgia tech which is which
universities better
uh well i have my opinions on that i
mean remember charles said
it doesn't matter what the facts are i'm
always right the correct thing
is that it doesn't matter they're
different um but
he went to a school like the school
where he is
as an undergrad i went to a school
specifically the same school
though it was it changed a bit in the in
the intervening years brown or georgia
tech no i was talking about georgia tech
and i went yeah and i went to an
undergrad place that's a lot like the
place where i work now and so it does
seem
like we're more familiar with these
models there's a similarity between
brown and yellow
yeah there's a i think that i think
they're quite similar yeah and duke
duke has some similarities too but it's
got a little southern
drawl you've kind of worked here you
sort of worked at universities that are
like the places where
you learned and
the same would be true for me are you
uncomfortable uh
venturing outside the box is that what
you're saying
journeying out what i'm saying yeah
charles is definitely he only goes to
places that have institute in the name
right
it has worked out that way well academic
places anyway
well no i was a visiting scientist at
upenn or visiting
visiting something at upenn oh wow i
just i just understood
your joke which one
five minutes later i like to set these
sort of time bombs
the institute is in the uh uh that
charles only goes to places that have
institute in the name
so i guess georgia i forget the georgia
tech is georgia institute of technology
the number of people who refer to it as
georgia tech university is large and
incredibly irritating
it's one of the few things that
generally gets under my schedule but
like schools like georgia tech and mit
have as part of the ethos like there is
i want to say there's a there's an
abbreviation that
someone taught me like i htfp something
like that like there's a there's a
there's an expression which is basically
i hate being here which they say
so proudly and that is definitely not
the ethos at brown like brown is
there's a little more pampering and
empowerment and stuff and it's not like
we're going to crush you and you're
going to love it
so yeah i think there's a i think the
ethos are different
mm-hmm that's interesting yeah we had
drown proofing
what's that challenge in order to
graduate from georgia tech this is a
true thing feel free to look it up uh
if you a lot of schools have this by the
way no actually georgetown was probably
the first brandeis has it
had it i feel like georgia tech was the
first in the look
of a lot of things it was it was the
first time i think um had the first time
stop that uh first masters in computer
science actually right online masters
well that too but way back in the 60s um
yeah yeah you're the first information
and
computer science master's degree in the
country um but
the uh georgia tech it used to be the
case in order to graduate from georgia
tech
uh you had to take a drown proofing
class where effectively they threw you
water tied you up if you didn't drown
you got to graduate
i believe so yeah there were certainly
versions of it but i mean luckily
they ended it just before i had to
graduate because otherwise would have
never graduated it wasn't going to
happen
i want to say 84 83 somewhere around
then they
they ended it but uh yeah you used to
have to prove you could tread water for
some ridiculous amount of time are you
kidding me you couldn't graduate no it
was more than two hours i thought it was
two minutes
okay and it was in a bathtub
it was in a pool but it was a real thing
but that idea that you know push you
fully clothed yeah fully clothed i don't
think i bet it was that and not tied up
because like who needs to learn how to
swim when you're tied nobody but who
needs to learn
when to swim when you're actually
falling into the water dressed that's a
real thing i think your facts are
getting in the way with a good story oh
that's fair that's fair i didn't
think all right so they tie you up the
narrative matters but whatever it was
you had to it was called drown proofing
for a reason the point of the story
michael uh is struggle it it's well no
but that's good
it does bring it back to struggle that's
a part of what georgia tech has always
been and we struggle with that by the
way
uh about what we want to be as things go
but you you sort of how much can you
be pushed without breaking and you come
out of the other end stronger right
there there's this saying we said when i
was an undergrad there which is georgia
tech
building tomorrow the night before right
there
kind of idea that you know give me
something impossible to do
and i'll do it in a couple of days
because that's what i just spent the
last four or five
or six years that ethos definitely stuck
to you
having now done a number of projects
with you you definitely will do it the
night before that's not entirely true
there's nothing wrong with waiting until
the last minute the secret is knowing
when the last minute is
right that's brilliant that's
brilliantly put yeah that yeah that's
that is a definite
charles statement that i am trying not
to embrace
i appreciate that because you helped
move my last minute that's the social
construct that we
converge together what the definition of
last minute is and we
we figure that out all together in fact
mit
you know i'm sure a lot of universities
have this but mit has like mit
time that yeah everyone has always
agreed
together that this there is such a
concept and everyone just keeps showing
up like
10 to 15 to 20 depending on the
department late to everything
so there's like a weird drift that
happens it's kind of fascinating yeah
we're five minutes
five minutes in fact the classes will
say you know well this is no longer true
actually but it used to be
a class was started eight but actually
started 805 it ends at nine actually it
ends at
55. uh everything's five minutes off and
nobody expects anything to start until
five minutes after the half hour
whatever it is
it still exists it hurts my head
you